thank you for tuning in to the
dean show this week back with us again
imam mustafa zaid and we're going to be
discussing
in detail some of the many proofs and
evidences
in particular on this week's episode
we're going to be talking about the
prophecies
we want proof we want to know that the
way of life that we're living it makes
sense worship the creator not the
creation
obey god and you get paradise and you
avoid the hellfire
but how can we be sure that this man
muhammad peace be upon him
was indeed a mighty messenger who he
claimed
that he was he said he was a messenger
he came with all these evidences
so we're going to be discussing some of
these today the many prophecies things
that he predicted that came to pass so
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
with imam mustafa zaid
here on the dean show
this is the angel
this is
now we know without a shadow of a doubt
that jesus peace be upon him
he was a mighty messenger of god he came
with the same message of
abraham moses and all the other
preceding messengers
ishmael isaac suleiman all of these were
messengers of god right
after jesus came muhammad yes we believe
in all of them muhammad being the final
prophet no more prophets to come
and we know that this matters a serious
man because we're going to die the
party's going to end
there's partying out there whatever kind
of party it is
it's coming we're gonna die and this
matter is serious so for the more
serious people
out there who want to know the purpose
of life why we've been created where
we're going when we die
the quran talks about it it talks about
everything all of these things
and the prophet muhammad peace be upon
him he came with evidences of proof the
living miracle is the quran we have it
in this original right yes
we also have these prophecies that you
listed in your book
yes and we're going to talk about on the
show why did you feel this is so
important to talk about this
as you know eddie i in my debates with
islamophobes
uh uh and many people about islam people
who try to put
clouds of doubts over islam it
most of the time boils down to the fact
that well
proved to me that the quran is the word
of god
prove to me the prophet muhammad peace
be upon him is the prophet of god
and i would follow but it has to be
scientific it has to be objective and
has to be without doubt
so from my experience even for muslims
we need to always try to
fortify our belief in allah subhanallah
in our hearts and try to
always give that fuel of certainty in
our hearts before even
give it to other people muslim or
non-muslim and it all boils down to the
mercy
that allah sent to us that is called
muhammad
sallallahu alaihi so in islamic
literature in islamic
and seerah there were these proofs there
were scholars of islam
who looked at these proofs in many books
that are known mainly by dalai lama or
the evidence and proofs
of the prophet of prophet muhammad and i
took it
from even an older part we went and did
research and discovered that
a a fact that a lot of people did not
know that all the prophets of allah
subhanahu ta'ala
a part of their message is the comment
of that one
final greatest of all prophets that will
make the message of allah complete
and perfect once and for all and the
matter of fact for example
the word gospel is a translation of the
aramaic word
injeel injeel in itself means the glad
tidings glad tidings of what
jesus peace be upon him in the quran
says
o sons of israel i came to you to
certify what's between my hands of the
torah
and give you the glad tidings give you
the gospel of
the coming of a prophet that will come
after me his name is ahmed
so throughout even the ibrah you know
the message of ibrahim alaihissalam
that filtered and got you know uh
changed and altered throughout history
in ancient history even in hindu
scriptures you would find prophet
muhammad
mentioned by name
and and and and the zora historians
books
zindavista and all that talking about a
prophet his name is ahmed
he would get sharia from his god that
it would be to him like light that he
gets from the light of his own god
even names of the enemies of prophet
muhammad
in the zorostorian's books is mentioned
by name
angra man you and it mentioned by name
and it describes prophet muhammad sallam
described the oneness
and the message of prophet muhammad as
we are talking about it
in the old testament prophet muhammad's
comment is mentioned
by name if you read the hebrew old
testament not the english one that you
have in today's bible
prophet muhammad name is mentioned
muhammad mean
delta in hebrew muhammad you cannot
be confused about it right there in the
old testament in the new testament
jesus christ upon him spoke about
prophethood so many times
specifically in the gospel of john about
the coming of that paraclete
paraclete which people translated
erroneously into spirit of truth
is paracletus in greek and if you ask
any greek linguistic
about what the meaning of it it is the
one
that is praised or the one with the name
that has many praises in it
so even the prophecies of the coming of
prophet muhammad
are right there look at the demographics
at the time of the coming from
out of the old arab peninsula which is a
huge area
the jewish population concentrated
heavily in medina and mecca
because in their old scripture the last
prophet of god who they hoped would be
jewish would come in that area and a lot
of people would not tell you that
half of the medina rabbis accepted islam
including the chief rabbi
abdullahi these were the scholars these
were the scholars of their time
of the time half of them accepted islam
including the chief rabbi
they accepted the message of submit to
the creator not to the creation islam
absolutely another very interesting
piece of information
when you look at christians they're
named after christ that is
hey jesus peace be upon him if you look
at
the jewish faith uh you know the
patriarch of the faith is
musa alaihissalam moses moses peace be
upon him
so the question comes what about all the
prophets of god
from adam alaihissalam all the way to
muslim
what were the followers of that creed
that
believe in the one mighty god called
what was their name
if you look at the original hebrew and
jewish scholars would tell you that
including
uh binyamin abramson who is the
historical reference
for all the course in tel aviv nowadays
he will tell you they had two names
depending on the
hebrew dialect that he used their names
before moses before jesus
were either muslim i or salamai
it's a known fact but a lot of people do
not know about it
so all that leads up to the coming of
prophet muhammed and prophet muhammad
sallam
comes finally so tell us now we we you
wrote a book now
and discussing in detail the prophecies
yes so when we say prophecy what do you
mean what is the prophecy what i meant
is the prophecies of the coming of
prophet muhammad
the prophecies that prophet muhammed
gave the followers
of the religion of allah that came true
in his life
that came true after he passed away that
are coming through right now
and his prophecies and that's most
importantly tell the end of the world
how the world
would evolve and end eventually so you
covered that right now you talked about
now the prophets of old that came before
him jesus who prophesized about prophet
muhammad and this is covered
yes okay and who else was it that told
about prophet muhammad coming
uh for example even in the old testament
other than mentioning the name of
prophet muhammad
by name muhammad which in the english
translation
made it into altogether lovely how only
allah knows
this is in the old testament in the old
testament in the old testament also in
the book of isaiah
12 29 uh it speaks about how the message
would be given to prophet muhammad
and the book will be given to him who's
not
learned and he would be asked to read
this and he would answer
i am not learned that's why i cannot
learn yeah
that's in isaiah yeah that's how the
revelation came
yes 29 12. and it it shows how the the
revelation is going to be given to that
prophet of god
and as we all know what happened the
first time that prophet muhammad
received the revelation
archangel gabriel told him read and
prophet muhammad says
i'm not learned exactly told in the old
testament
and throughout as we said the gospel of
john so many times or jesus peace be
upon him even
gives a word-for-word translation
of suratul allah
he reveals to you what is being revealed
to him exactly
and the gospel of john 16 12 jesus peace
be upon him
says that he the spirit of truth spirit
of truth meaning the paracletes or the
praised one
muhammad peace be upon him is going to
tell about me and whatever he would tell
you
is not of his own self but he tells you
what is being revealed to him and he
didn't come with nothing different from
jesus he came with the same message same
exact message worship the creator
not the creation yeah this is the same
message absolutely believe in god don't
worship
don't worship jesus exactly jesus peace
be upon him used to pray to god so
why worship jesus exactly while you know
the creator is there exactly so we're
going to come back with more
of the prophecies we're going to talk
about some of the details that the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
he predicted they happen and that's here
on the dean show we'll be right back
this is my family
that he's always been stubborn
come on get him from the station
one fight here another fight there his
physical being
was great for his ego but it left him
empty
i'm running here running there
on the outside people looking in and
said hey this is the man
everybody knew eddie at any given moment
he could have seven to eight women
that are running around the club looking
for him
he did things that he uh he pushed
himself to the ethical extremes that he
could
i have to get out of this
right near the end there was just a boy
it was a constant struggle
his inner soul was broken at that moment
there was that emptiness in his eyes it
was a bigger emptiness that i think
i've ever really seen in his eyes
it was dr jackal mr hyde and he was
struggling with that but the effort was
there
there's a conscious effort to make that
switch who hasn't started talking behind
his back look at him he's starting to be
a
good guy
this was the reality
people to be on the show
that the first episode of that
show aired i think that's when you saw
the full formation coming to
this guy's changed what's going on here
he's a machine i know
to see someone change to see their
character changes to see
positive changes in their life it's a
sign of god
back here on the dean show imam mustafa
zayd
you you mentioned the world word earlier
before we get into the prophecy you
mentioned islamophobes
yes you know people who just hate other
people because they're muslim
is this is you know these no people in
my experience it's beyond that it's
people who
make a living inciting hatred against
muslims
haters yes they're incite hatred what
they want you
is to hate muslims and discriminate
against muslim and justify
if their backers do whatever they want
to do to muslims on a country level or
an individual level
then you let it go because you hate
muslims they made you hate muslims yeah
so you have these people that are out
there that make it a business on
bashing islam and muslims muslims yes
the fastest growing religion
in the world and in america this is a
shame because this is indeed from the
creator and we're giving some of the
evidence as it proves
we've discussed so many on prior
episodes
today we're talking about the prophecies
so tell us now
if somebody for the skeptic out there he
said look you know nostradamus
he made some prophecies what's the big
deal
was he wasn't a prophet or you know this
doesn't prove that he was a man
i you know nostradamus real quick he was
a seer a jewish scholar
who turned christian at the time of the
inquisitions and he was afraid that they
would attack him so he wrote what they
called qua trains
and predicted things to happen in the
future in in a
in a vague kind of way and sometimes
they find half of it correct and half of
it not and so on and so forth
if you compare that to the prophets of
prophet muhammad
as we were talking it's the difference
between day
and nightmare yeah you you can tell
subhanallah you would not call him a
prophet not even by a mile
compared to prophet muhammad for example
prophet muhammed and one of the darkest
moments
in the history of islam when all muslims
are about 315 persecuted
uh starved and and fought for the past
10 years
and they're fighting the battle of
bedrock against the strong
mighty warriors of christ that are three
times the size
and subhanallah allah subhanahu wa
reveals to prophet muhammad says
this is the point it's not the
prophecies of the prophet himself
it is what allah enables him and reveals
to him
he went to the area where they would
have the battle and pointed to the
location
this is where this infidel would
be killed and this area when this other
one would die and so on and so forth
by location after allah grants the
muslims
the great victory of badr the first
victory in the history of islam
the companions of sallam were astonished
when they walked around in the battle
and exactly the same people the prophet
muhammad sallam said would be killed
in exactly the same locations how the
prophet muhammad says
so his companions later are narrating
this narrating this
that we're not talking about people 500
years later
in a hidden scripture somewhere in some
desert it's the people
who were contemporary and who listened
to prophet muhammed
the night prior seeing it with their own
eyes in the battlefield
tell us some more prophet muhammad in
another moment and this is
amazing when now quray said that we have
to summon the biggest army in our
history
and go in the battle of the trench and
annihilate muhammad till the end of him
and islam so the only solution the very
small amount of muslims in medina to do
is dig a trench around medina
so a horse cannot leap up over
and actually you cannot go out there and
invade
medina while they were starving to the
limit that prophet muhammed had two
stones
tied to his stomach to fight the hunger
like the rest of the companions
they are calling prophet muhammad says
oh prophet of allah he was about 54
years of age
uh there's a huge rock in one trench and
we cannot
break it was one the most physically
powerful
man in the arab peninsula and and that's
a different story
he goes from mumma and he says allahu
and hit the rock one hit
and one third of it split and he tells
him you know what in that moment
i see the the
palaces of shem area which is
lebanon palestine syria and jordan that
area
in asia and was the center of the
byzantium
empire open to islam and i see us
getting into its palaces
and they say bismillah and hits the rock
again allahu akbar
and another piece comes off and he said
i see the medain which is the capital of
the persian empire
are in the hands of muslims and we're
getting there and then he
said one third time and destroyed
completely the rock and said and i see
yemen i see us getting into sana'a
at the moment where you're about to be
annihilated and subhanallah in the same
sequence
in the same happening all these areas
were opened to islam
and the army of the quraish with the
conspirators of the tribe of venus come
in and a mighty wind comes
and destroy their tents and put off
their fires and they say we cannot fight
this fight and they go back and
subhanallah
islam the rest is history how would
prophet muhammad say i know this
and it happened are you talking about a
persecuted minority that about to be
annihilated and you're talking about you
know what
we will be in america we'll be in the
soviet union and we'll take japan too
and these things came to pass came to
pass exactly the same sequence
now was there also a similar situation
where
a man was coming and he was trying to on
his horse catch up to the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
that's what actually i started the book
with that miracle
can you go ahead and absolutely prophet
muhammad
his life from assassination plot that
the tribes of quraysh
had against them and subhanallah he had
a head
distance over the man whose name surah
najasan
the best tracker that quraysh had had on
his mighty horse and he started to get
closer to prophet muhammed
and he was shocked that abu bakr saw the
campaign of prophet muhammed seeing him
but prophet muhammed said i've never
turned back even though
abu bakr told them you know that guy's
about to come and kill us he's right
behind us pram
says i've never looked back and then he
got closer and he thought that you know
what
now i got him and i'm going to get the
fortune that quran offered me
and all of a sudden his mighty horse and
he's one of the most skillful
uh nights just stumbled and you know he
fell in the ground him and the horse
he said well a bizarre coincidence
mounted his horse again and started two
chased after prophet muhammed he got
closer all of a sudden
a supernatural thing happened all of a
sudden the hard desert floor
became like liquid mud the two front
legs of the horse
when they're sank in it as if it's
liquid mud even though it's locked by
the hard desert
you just somebody put your hand in
cement and let it dry and then you
cannot move
then surah realized that you know what
i'm not the best headhunter
out there and and tracker because i
cannot see the writing
on the wall this is the prophet of god
so he called abu bakr and asked him
to give him peace and he is not going to
harm anything iframe
but just wish to give him a pledge that
the muslims would not hurt him later on
at this moment prophet muhammad sallam
looks and gaze into his eyes and says
that you would wear the golden cuffs of
cicero that he's very known with these
fancy
cuffs that cecil puts on his hand that
was the leader of the
the persian empire it's just like how
would you like to
get the scepter of the king of england
for example it's him in a harsh desert
and he was about to be killed
and subhanallah
comes after abu bakr and they go and
open persia
and the entire land as prophet muhammad
predicted and then comes the treasure he
opens and there's the cloak of cicero
there's a golden cuffs of uh uh
uh it came became king to pass and he
called surah who became a muslim at the
time and he said so
put him on and where see we know most of
these things now
some many don't but for the people that
know we know that okay
many of these prophecies the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him he predicted
they came to pass these weren't vague
you know
things that you have to like you know
do so much you know mental work to try
to figure it out it's like a mystery
they're clear but you know for the
person that's an atheist the person that
you know
a skeptic we boast about the quran we
have the verbatim word of god is that
right yes that's a living miracle
but on top of that these are the details
that blow your mind too
and i think we are not fair to as you
said non-muslims or atheist brothers
because we speak to them as if they know
the you know
facts that we know one fact is that not
only prophet muhammad is the most
biographed man in history but he is the
most accurately quoted man in history
and a matter of fact the science of how
objectively
you can certify that a prophet or a
person in history have said this exactly
was founded by muslim scholars
specifically
where they memorized the biographies of
2 000 people
and made sure that this person who said
that i said this
is certified by other people who have
implicable reputation never lied
and there were contemporaries at the
same time in the same city
and then out of 60 000 correct
quotations of the prophet
for example in the book sahih al-bukhari
that is the ultimate reference
there's about 6 000 quotations that we
know for a fact that the prophet had
said that
because it's narrated by the people who
lived with the prophet with their names
with their biographies one after the
other after the other and these are
carried
in the books so when we say that surah
said this
and abu bakr witnessed that it did
happen
and there was not one second that we
missed that historical
information or someone has any doubt
about it ever
so it happened it happened it happened
and we're gonna be back with
more of some of these prophecies from
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind the prophet muhammad who was the
brother to jesus moses abraham who came
with the same message worship the
creator
not the creation we'll be right back
with more here on the dean's show
why don't you want to pray is he not
worthy of praise and
thanks i mean think about all the
blessings that we have of allah he
created you he's the one that feeds you
he's the one that takes care of you
the ability to see one unbelievable
blessing
and he loves you start fresh today
a new page a new beginning and reach out
to the one who created you and ask him
for guidance
back here on the dean's show and we're
talking about the prophecies
the evidences the proofs that this man
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
was indeed who he claimed he was a
messenger of god
and he didn't come with some strange
message
you know what the cool thing is that
it's simple to understand
worship the one who created you the
creator don't worship the creation
do good be good live a righteous
wholesome
organic life and you get paradise and
you avoid the hellfire
it's not asking you to believe in santa
claus is it no no
it's straightforward and when you
compare the message of jesus because
nowhere did jesus ever claim he was god
worship him
all of this other stuff that people just
you know made up and concocted
you'll see that that message that jesus
that pure message of pure monotheism
that jesus came that's the same message
that muhammad came and moses and abraham
so i mean it's just easy to digest isn't
it absolutely the old prophets of the
same
message of the oneness of god oneness of
god is the last prophet of god
and if you if you have a bible if you
have an old testament and look at the
words of the prophets themselves not
man-made theology or man-made claims
they would be talking like me and you
are talking about the same exact concept
and ideology worship the oneness of god
do righteous
do not hurt people like for others would
you like for yourself and that's the
message of islam
so tell us some more give us some more
we're almost out of time subhanallah
predicted that constantinople would be
open to islam the most immune
city probably in the history of mankind
which is in turkey today
and it was prohibited said you will open
egypt to islam
the capital of the byzantine empire in
africa
uh heraculous said that is
alexandria which was the capital of
egypt at the time would fall
then the entire eastern byzantine empire
would go down
and guess what the muslims opened that
uh prophet muhammed subhan allah
you know had had this miracle of seeing
things
that people did not even know yet at the
battle of muta
uh um passed away he was the leader and
then there was a hierarchy in the army
jaffa arun abi talib passed away he was
killed in the battle
and then abdullah ibn at the same thing
and it was then
leader of islam that was the first
battle that he led the muslim army
and actually saved the muslim army from
annihilation when it happened as it was
happening prophet muhammed was given
a khutbah and and prabhupada system
started to weep and told people
what was happening as it happened even
though he was not there he didn't have a
cell phone
he didn't have a cnn and subhanallah and
people witnessed this
how would prophet muhammad muhammad
one of his uh famous quotations in the
book about uh one of the signs of the
hour that we were talking about
two signs that are major science that
prophet muhammad predicted 1400 years
ago
he said the beginning of the hour would
be two signs the first one
is that people who were shepherd who
were barefooted
would be competing with each other in
building the highest buildings now
that's in
arab lands now in our lands there's
nothing wrong with that allah
blessed the people of immigrants in
saudi arabia with the
you know revenues of oil and so on so
forth what is the highest building in
the world now
the needle or khalifa tower in dubai you
would never thought that back so many
years ago that
and i was there in the 70s when they
were actually shepherding
you know sheep and all that kind of
stuff and oil was kind of new to them
and i was alive then so prophet muhammed
predicted this 1400 years ago said that
the people
in this area now the shepherds are going
to be competing over
and not only that they would build it
what is the next highest building that
is predicted to
be opened in 2018 the tower
building in saudi arabia wow how would
promise i said i know it's happening
but the second one which is the most
amazing one that we talked about
and allah had blessed me about seven
years ago of deciphering for the first
time
with the blessing of allah subhana
ta'ala and talib
that the maid would give birth to her
master how would a maid in the same
moment of birth would be given birth to
her own
master and it's her own baby and
subhanallah tell
the concept of surrogate mothership
where
some couple usually wealthy they have
reproduction problems so
they artificially inseminate uh the
the egg of the real mother and then
planted in another
mother's womb sometimes her sister and
sometimes they hire somebody
but legal problems came out of that and
somebody says no that's my baby
and that's your baby and so and so forth
so what the wealthiest people do
nowadays is that they have the maid in
the house
they trust her she works for them for
years and she would be the one
she who would be taking care of that
baby anyway so what happens that they
hire the maid
make her the biological mother that
carry that egg
and then the maid would be given birth
when she gives birth
to her own master from mohammed sallam
talked about this as a sign
of the beginning of the end of time
subhanallah 1400 years ago
how could you possibly imagine that
someone know that and most importantly
prophet muhammad says
i will not tell you no it's not me
if i knew myself on my own independently
the unknown i would have brought all
good things to me and nothing
would have harmed me but everything i do
is with the willing with the power of
allah amazing so look we have like 30
seconds
left go ahead and let the people know if
they want to get this book
inshaallah the book is called the
prophecies of muhammad
it's available on amazon.com and barnes
and noble
the book has not just the prophecies of
from
sallam but also the miracles one of the
things that we need to let people know
is that
there's not one miracle that a prophet
of god had performed
that prophet muhammad sallallahu did not
do and then some more
so we list the miracles of prophet
muhammad i put a challenge an
international press release that
anyone that reads that book 350 pages
and does not believe
and prophet muhammed can come to me
it's impossible you can say well i know
he's the prophet i'm not gonna follow
him but he cannot tell me that this is
not
the prophet of god and it's a proof of
the existence of god on top
of the miracles of the quran that we
have there so we need to give it to our
own children
especially in public schools to cement
the belief in allah
in in their hearts we need to give them
to friends and families and
and people around us who are muslim or
non-muslim
to make dawah with islam for them and
use it as zakah for yourself as and one
who invites
to the pastor of allah subhanallah thank
you very much
i hope to see you soon and it'd be a
shame
if you went through life and you didn't
get to know this man
this man wasn't calling you to worship
him nor did jesus or moses or any
of god's messengers he was calling you
to original goodness
that's right that thing in life they'll
bring you
peace happiness contentment and then
paradise end because we're all going to
die
j day of judgment accountability you
think you're just going to ride by
cruise by
in this life and not be accountable for
all the treacherous things that you
might have done
so now is the time to get it right
repent to god call upon god the one god
ask for forgiveness do it right now call
upon
the creator and ask him to guide you and
he'll facilitate away
and get to know this man you heard us
mention some of the evidence is improved
but the living miracle that we have
that's tamper-free temper proof is the
verbatim word of god the quran that'd be
a shame if you
didn't read this book and you read every
other book out there
every other fashion magazine so
get to know this prophet get to know him
because he was sent to you as a mercy to
the world
and don't let this life pass by and then
when you die it's too late you can't
come back
and then the hellfire is real paradise
is real and you didn't do
anything to avoid the hellfire and to
gain the paradise and the mercy of the
creator
so really think about it
and don't fool yourself all right and we
hope to see you again here on the dean
show give us a call if you have some
questions operator is standing by
18062 islam we'll see you next time
god willing until then peace be with you
you